tu le sais tu vas être mrs.
marteau noir as-tu dit à mon frère
que le petit clown sort avec ma sœur
oh mec intelligent quelle est ta bénédiction et
demande à ta sœur de se marier tu me dis
que tu es digne d'elle je ne suis pas
censé faire ça je vais te prendre  un
trajet aujourd'hui est votre journée de formation
tous les nouveaux concessionnaires d'Atlanta sont
approvisionnés par Antonio Pope à
Miami vous devez me trouver quelque chose sur
ce gars deux jours en haut désolé mais les
adultes pour avoir parlé Ben vous êtes à peine en
probation  officier Oh James, si
vous voulez l'emmener à Miami, vous pouvez alors
réunir une équipe et résoudre ce problème, vous
feriez mieux de vous préparer, venez ici mec,
non, il est trop tôt, votre
partenaire épouse votre sœur, le flic de sexe big talk
courney est le meilleur organisateur de mariage  à
Atlanta alors qu'est-ce que tu vas faire je ne suis
pas intimidé par toi ce que tu vas faire
les beaux-frères viennent d'arriver en ville tu
dis ça encore une fois te tirer une balle dans le visage la
contrebande à travers le port tu vas
aider  moi obtenir des preuves tangibles oh je
ne pense pas  Je vais abandonner mon nom en
donnant un coup d'œil est-ce qu'il est autre que toi Tasha
parce que non passé par son téléphone le
prénom que j'ai rencontré était l'appeler dire qui
appelait c'était sa sonnerie
puis j'ai joué ta sonnerie ça ne coûte
absolument rien
Je suis venu ici, j'ai eu une boîte de nuit qui a déposé 20
plaintes pour intrusion
et une voiture a explosé pendant que j'allais
dans une voiture piégée ouais, mais nous avons fait d'autres
trucs, votre partenaire James, nous nous protégeons
les nerfs, c'est
mauvais oh il est sur moi